but this is not the only way to graph
this okay I can graph this with a on the
vertical axis and r-squared on the
horizontal axis so draw for me
underneath you draw for me another set
of axes it can be identical in size so
for this yeah I'm always white so for
this new graph here the horizontal
access needs to be labeled a little bit
differently it'll be R squared so now
when we had 0 and radius of 0 and an
area of 0 that's still going to be here
okay but now what I want to do is I'm
going to plot these same values for R
squared not for R this is a little bit
weird
so remember when R is equal to 1 R is
equal to 1 you've got an area of pie
right 3.14 okay so I'm gonna put that on
and when I say 1 over here say and I
think 60 was up here so all my vertical
markings are still the same okay but now
as I go forward I think I've made that
too big but I'll find out in a second
now as I go forward I'm not going to
label when R equals 2 I want to know
what R squared is when R equals 2 so
what's R squared where R is 2 R squared
will be 4 right so I'm gonna go across
not to 2 but to four so I've got a
smaller scale here 3 2 3 4
yeah I've definitely made this too small
but that's okay okay
when R is equal to 2 R squared is 4 and
the area you guys told me was what was
it again what was your second area that
you got go ahead put it in 4 pi it's
gonna be 12 point five six something
like that okay so
I'm gonna put that in here okay let me
let me rewind a little bit let me rewind
a little bit because it is a bit we
didn't Ricky what we're doing he was I
would ask you for a value of our like
say one and then I'll ask you to find
out what the area was okay now down here
I'm doing exactly the same thing but I'm
not asking you for a value of R I'm
asking for a value of R squared okay all
right how about this one here when R
equals three what's R squared it's nine
so on my horizontal axis I'm gonna go
all the way to nine summit for the
moment five six seven eight nine okay
what was the area this time nine times
pi this is the twenty eight ish one was
it 28 or so
hi which kind those are this some how
many do you need
is that enough cuz I think I only have
ten max I have keys hold on how many are
there can you count and you need more
than that you reckon that's enough okay
we'll come back and let me know if you
need did you confirm for me was it
twenty eight twenty eight ish okay so
I'm gonna find where that is
twenty-eight somewhere around here okay
now my last one I haven't made this
quite big enough so I'm gonna make this
go a little further my last one was for
R equals four see that when R equals
four what is R squared 16 so I'm at nine
right now so I'm gonna go 10 11 12 13 14
15 16
there we go now what was the value
Eliana said 50 in a bit right 50 and a
bit so that's going to be somewhere
around
yeah I'd say okay now I want you to look
at these points again this is the cool
bit on this you got a parabola right
because you're predictably you had
something squared but what's happening
here
it's a straight line right why is that
it's because what I'm comparing is a
versus r-squared I need to rewrite this
and remember they are directly in
proportion which means a straight line
okay so what I can do is I can graph a
against R or alternatively I can graph a
against R square I could graph it agates
are cute or out of the power of 4
anything I really like okay if i graph a
against something that it's directly
proportional to you will always get a
straight line okay so the equation of
this line is exactly the same as what we
had before this is a equals PI R squared
this is also a equals PI R squared but
my axes are different do you see that my
axes are different so you get a
different shape because you're comparing
a different kind of quantity sure okay
so I'll go through it step-by-step right
what you want to do is you find a value
for your independent variable okay so
say R equals four okay
when R equals four what's a equal to and
you said it was 50 point whatever 50
point two six bundle of law is that one
was yep so now you know what value for a
you should do so I went up to a 50 or
wherever that was okay but now when I
look at the horizontal thing I don't
plot R equals four because it's not an
our axis it's a squared axis so I need
to know what R squared is which in this
case is 16 okay so these guys are my
coordinates that guy there is 16 comma
50 point two six etc okay so dude just
like you did before but your extra step
is you've got to know what this axis is
actually talking about which is R
squared in this case
okay yeah so you will often be asked
your sometimes we ask graph a against
this or graphed a against that and
depending what they ask you to graph
against your axes will be different your
shape will be different okay